on va continuer à regarder ce qui s'est
passé en sport ce qui va se passer et ce
qui s'est passé on va parler aussi des
résultats lors de cette chronique juste
pour rappeler que vous aviez delpy du
club de saint quentin en yvelines est le
nouveau champion d'europe d'apnée c'est
ça dans l'épreuve du jump blues au
détenteur du record du monde 185 m on va
essayer encore de l'avoir en ligne d'ici
la fin de cette édition pour qu'il
puisse réagir à ce titre qu'il a obtenu
c'était il ya tout juste quelques jours
on continue donc à parler de sport et on
va parler de n'obtenant qualitas
l'antennagate or vous souvenez wilfried
on l'avait accueilli sur ce plateau il
ya mi septembre juste après ses belles
performances aux jeux paralympiques de
londres où elle avait ramené une très
belle médaille de bronze sur le 100 m
malvoyants j'ai eu la chance d'assister
à sa toute première reprise
d'entraînement il ya quelques jours en
compagnie d'elodie moines revenir à
l'entraînement et faire ses premières
foulées
c'est toujours ce moment si particulier
où il faut passer à autre chose
un mois et demi après une compétition
extraordinaire comme les jeux
paralympiques
une coupure pendant laquelle nantenin
keita licenciés a lieu à saint quentin a
dû gérer la décompression post olympique
mais la déception de ne pas être revenu
avec le plus beau métal de londres est
encore présente dans un coin de la tête
mais je sais quand même la compétition
ultime suprême c'est c'est tous les
quatre on est aujourd'hui je suis à un
âge avancé et je sais pas si j'aurai la
chance d'en faire d'autres
donc oui mais il ya quand même le goût
amer parce que parce que parce que ça
finit par chenilles pas sur un piano ou
paralympiens de que je voulais en fait
donc et je pense que nous sommes goût
amer je mourrai
je l'aurais pendant longtemps son
objectif même si elle ne dit pas c'est
un jour de décrocher une médaille d'or
aux jeux olympiques donc c'est ça c'est
un vrai objectif
donc il ya un goût amer parce que
parce qu'elle n'a pas eu à pékin elle
pas la sphère argent et bronze là elle
fait une bronze c'est toujours parce
qu'elle voudrait la principale
préoccupation est tout autre pour
l'instant éviter les blessures ces
douleurs qui ont miné l'athlète
saint-quentinoise ces deux dernières
saisons je pense que mon corps est
fatigué et qu'en fait mon corps je n'ai
jamais ménagé
au bout d'un moment il dit stop parce
que c'est vrai j'ai fait pas mal de
saisons je m'entraînais dur et où il n'y
avait pas de suivi médical derrière et
j'ai une façon de courir en fait qui est
assez brutal pour mon corps donc vous
kouba web ou dans les craques d'antonin
court désormais vers son prochain
objectif les championnats du monde à
lyon en juillet 2013 avant de se laisser
peut-être tentés par de nouveaux défis
comme le 400 m haies pendant que londres
s'efface foulée après foulée les ranger
elle a fait un petit parcours là parce
que j'ai fait pas mal de l'intervention
la semaine dernière donc à chaque fois
de ramener la médaille mais mais ça et
c'est bon là les rangées chapitres
suivants s'appuie très sûr
et puisque c'est la page de ce sport en
parle de tous les sports tous veille de
tous les sports alors wilfried est son
rôle
ça vous va vous avez bien lu ting et kin
ball n'ont absolument pas alors la base
de balle bien joué oui mais ça marche
comme ça ce sont des sports de balle
pourtant avec des noms assez étrange et
bien les jeunes manicouagan traire -
vous savez jouer maintenant
et parce que pendant les vacances il
fallait les voir voilà vous pourrez vous
pourrez apprendre tous à la retraite
avec les jeunes de vie de 12 ans pendant
les vacances les jeunes maniaient quoi
suivaient des stages de sports organisée
par la ville et on a pu découvrir aussi
accompagné des lieux-dits moines ces
nouveaux sports le tube all et le kin
ball de nom étrange pour des sports de
balle plutôt simple expérimenté pendant
les vacances à magny les hameaux
pourtant si les jeunes manica sont
séduits reste que les règles ne sont pas
encore tout à fait assimiler
à quoi tu as joué au football
qu'est ce que c'est le patron
c'est une balle qu'on lance sur une
sorte de trampoline et qui ont la fin
d'exercice et fallait c'est une balle
enflammé il fallait passer le plus de
balles
de leur côté des adversaires le tube
bull vient de suisse et c'est une sorte
de passe à dix améliorer mélangeant
handball volley et squash piles et de se
faire des passes sans que l'adversaire
puisse les intercepter c'est ensuite de
tirer dans la cible il faut que la balle
rebondisse par terre avant que
l'adversaire ne les rattrape et voilà
donc il n'y a pas de cible qui est
propre à chacune des équipes
le kin ball vient du canada c'est ce
sport spectaculaire où les joueurs
peuvent se saisir du ballon avec toutes
les parties du corps
l'idée étant qu'il ne rebondisse pas au
sol coûte que coûte au kin-ball c'est
c'est alors non on appelle ça en fait
pour ceux qui jouent un peu dans la rue
avant je jouais au dauphin dauphine donc
c'était on envoyait un ballon on
appelait un prénom et on devait le
rattraper ben là c'est un peu le même
principe ça joue pas sur trois équipes
composées de quatre joueurs et donc il y
à un protocole pour l'appellation de
l'équipe puis doit aller récupérer le
ballon et donc ce gros ballon qui est
envoyé en l'air doit être récupéré par
un ou plusieurs membres de l'équipe qui
a été appelé avant qu'ils ne tombent par
terre
si cette équipe là n'arrivent pas à le
récupérer c'est les deux autres équipes
qui obtiennent les ponts en fait les
animateurs de manier la mauve elle
derrière la découverte de ces deux
sports faire passer un message aux
enfants aussi bien de tchouk que le kin
ball sont des activités sportives ou les
enfants sont jamais mis en contact il
n'ya pas d'insécurité les enfants sont
là sont pas livrés à se faire mal en
tout cas et c'est non énormément basée
sur la notion de respect et de fair play
en france une trentaine de clubs
proposent la pratique du tout et du
kinball notre choc alors ça y est vous
êtes un familier de choses à nous
apprendre à la rédaction comment ça
marche
on va faire des tournois je crois à
faire des tournois de pétanque haussier
oui tout en admettant que ce jeudi un
1er novembre l'amicale des boules
plaisir was a organisé son traditionnel
grand prix annuel ça c'est plus facile
c'est plus simple un feuilleté aux tirs
et ses plus importantes et où le tir ça
dépend du sens du vent et donc qu'il y
avait 2 195 doublettes venues de toute
l'île de france qui s'affrontaient et
c'est la paire du mesnil-le-roi asys
farouk et amine belle mais sabia qui
s'est imposé et parmi les boulistes un
tireur d'élite étaient présents je veux
parler évidemment de dylan rocher
c'est le tout nouveau champion du monde
de pétanque en triplettes à tout juste
20 ans il a délivré ses impressions sur
ce titre à guillaume qu'en ce bas c'est
sûr que je paie du monde voilà ici on
sanaryens à chance de le gagner on ne
peut pas être plus haut quoi je dirais
puis bon surtout que ça s'est passé à
marseille avec 6000 spectateurs
voilà c'est y avait une ambiance
particulière ouais je me suis entraîné
tout petits avec mes frères mon père
voilà petit à petit j'étais dans une
école de pétanque puis après j'ai fait
deux trois compétitions avec mon père
voilà précités parti quoi j'ai fait les
sélections en juniors pour l'équipe de
france j'ai été sectionnés puis après
j'étais championne du monde ça et puis
bah pareil en seniors donc
moi c'est vrai que ça va vite quoi
essayer d'en avoir le plus possible des
ti des champions du monde et puis au
niveau des shows pead france voilà et
c'est de ramener pas mal quoi et comme
promis nous avons relié à présent xavier
delpy bonsoir avant on enlevait les del
pi merci d'être avec nous champion
d'europe de blue jump up with the blue
job je crois qu'il ya qu un seul mot et
xavier ses félicitations à tous on
espère et on prête et au delà de ce
titre européen il ya un beau record du
monde à la clé avec 185 m c'est ça voilà
donc avec la même marque que moi alors
l'humanité d'être pas encore fait en
attendant xavier delpy du club de saint
quentin en yvelines club de plongée le
blue jump avec ce titre fait de l'apnée
ça oui ça d'apnée c'est de l'apnée
exactement expliquez-nous un petit peu
le sco quoi consiste le bund job alors
le bouquin l'épreuve un petit peu entre
la piscine et l'apnée en mer ou en mer
normalement sont des épreuves roja en
profondeur et l'organisation mondiale
qui est la cma avait arrêté en suisse il
raconté dans leur ombre d'assurer la
sécurité de l'épreuve qui a trouvé un
petit peu dangereux avec la maîtrise de
la profondeur qui était difficile donc
elle a inventé une épreuve qui était un
petit peu en profondeur on descend à 10
mètres et ensuite on va faire de toute
obédience possible autour d'un carré qui
se tient de mettre de côté avec les
nombres un petit peu de deux défendent
de maîtrise du milieu de la mer un petit
peu d'actifs et des fêtes qui fit qu'on
a travaillé en vidéo en cliquant ici
les bons résultats de la semaine
dernière et fiscales pendant que vous
parlez on voit des images injustement
d'entraînement lorsque anthony justement
vous étiez allait le suivre ce champion
du club de versailles est un petit
rectification tout à l'heure j'ai parlé
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ces clubs
de versailles oui et donc ça fait deux
ans et demi que vous pratiquez l'apnée à
haut niveau l'accension est fulgurante
j'ai envie de dire vous vous pensiez
atteindre ce niveau là jeudi dernier
espère secrètement en toute logique je
l'espérais plutôt dans vingt ou devant
les éléments qu'on a mis en place avec
françois j'espère que ton entraîneur qui
est en guadeloupe tout le staff de
l'équipe de france pour entraîner et
suit toute la cohésion de l'équipe de
france dans ce championnat
ce jour là je me suis vraiment senti
très très fort très en confiance c'est
ce que c'est ce que vous me disiez
canton c'était quand on vous avez suivi
un entraînement justement vous me disiez
que il y avait un rêve de podium mais
que la médaille d'or ça pouvait être
être compliqué voyez fait toujours très
aléatoire pour nous on n'a vraiment que
peu différente
voilà la condition publique la pet lykke
li fiq et le mental qui est importante
incroyable sur fait l'épreuve romana
multiple champion du monde et recordman
du monde différemment coulée qui a
craqué je suis passé devant être honnête
encore le niveau de votre ferr tendance
alors après eux
ce jour là je trouve pourvu on est par
ailleurs fort moment j'étais sur une
autre planète ou un autre sur une autre
vague peut-être c'était pas trop dur à
gérer latente entre les deux jours parce
qu'il ya eu le jour de qualification et
le lendemain c'était c'était la finale
on parle souvent de cette attente qui
peut être interminable où où la pression
augmente vite sur trois est ce qu on
avait eu le premier jour d'échauffement
d'entraînement sur le découvre voilà
bien avant les lectures qui le financera
mais depuis des mois effectivement très
bas comme dans tous les sports
comme les athlètes qui sont à vendre la
chambre d'appel qui doivent attendre
sa particularité de déplacement ont
céderait ses pauvres 5h30 du matin pour
aller prendre le bus et puis le bateau
quatre heures de transport leur arrivée
sur le site et la compétition ce que je
fais de la merde pas juste appuyé sur
laquelle on rails qu'il faut regarder
les autres pas fait c'est une malheur de
voir ma collègue sophie jacquin qui
était champion du monde en bas à la
sortie de son étrave trois quarts
d'heure en jeu pas là pour le mental à
dire beaucoup plus difficile j'ai envie
de lui faire plaisir devant de sa
défection
et vous l'avez bien changé avec ce titre
donc deux ans recordman maintenant
recordman du monde de champion d'europe
de blue jump voilà d'apnée merci et
xavier delpy d'avoir été en ligne avec
nous même si votre planning est chargé
d'avoir trouvé quelques minutes pour
témoigner d'après ce que je suis merci à
vous anthony il nous reste encore un peu
de temps pour parler sport quelques
résultats on reprend le cours des des
résultats sport on parle de football
tout d'abord oui football aucune
victoire ce week-end pour l'efsc
l'aubinois que nous suivons gtv fils
trappe s'est incliné 2 buts à 1 face à
colombes malgré une nette domination en
première période les trappistes reste
neuvième de leur championnat de
promotion d'honneur
de leur côté les joueurs de guyancourt
sont passés complètement à côté de leur
match sur la pelouse de linas montlhéry
défaite 5 buts à 2 et enfin en division
d'honneur en dh cette fois versailles
n'a pas dû digérer son élimination en
coupe de france la semaine dernière le
fcb s'est incliné sur la pelouse des
mureaux 3 buts à 2 balles on avait
quitté le club de montigny le bretonneux
en mauvaise position handball féminin
est ce que ça va mieux aller les ennemis
monteyne accumulé les défaites et puis
après bas donc trois villes trois
défaites consécutives en championnat les
joueuses de stéphane paysans se sont
imposés ce week-end enfin à plum rond
face à plus grand pardon 30 à 23 malgré
une affirme une infirmerie pleine
les joueuses de stéphane paysans
retrouvent le goût de la victoire et
notamment avec 10 buts de la cuisine
capitaine gabriel par le web quelques
images et ce dernier but voire de
montigny le bretonneux sport féminin
mais basket basket
les basketteuses de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles qu'on avait suivi il
ya quelques quelques jours refuse
toujours la défaite
les joueuses de vinko parties sont
enchaînées avec une septième victoire
consécutive face à gravenchon ce week
end
score final 58 à 53 elle reste
logiquement en tête de leur poule de
nationale 2 on quitte le sport féminin
pour parler du sport masculin et les
défaites qui se poursuivent pour le
roller hockey style en cours oui le
roller hockey il n'y a pas eu d'exploit
malheureusement c'est tout à fait
logique pour les chocs d'elancourt en
coupe de france 64e tout 64e de finale
de coupe de france ils ont été battus
par ris orangis sur un score assez
sévère je le dis et wilfrid vu que j'ai
déjà le chiffre sous les yeux non ça
trop sévère donc s'il faut donner
l'information quand même malgré tout
vous à 2 2 ap 2 effectivement c'est très
saine
leur priorité chez pour les chocs sens
et de ces deux championnats dont il n'y
a pas d'inquiétude à avoir cet enjeu
nous avait fait tourner l'effectif pour
ce match c'est en général ce qu'on dit
quand ça se passe mal leur coupe la
priorité c'est le championnat
championnat exactement à une info qui
concerne le psg du football oui du
football coup de théâtre
dans le choix de la ville qui
accueillera le nouveau centre
d'entraînement du paris saint germain à
la recherche d'une surface minimale de
30 hectares le club de la capitale
semblait avoir jeté son dévolu sur saint
germain en laye évidemment et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais ces derniers jours frédérik bernard
le maire ps de poissy aurait rencontré
la direction du psg un entretien à
priori décisif puisque le maire qui est
soutenu par ses élus qui viennent de
voter landes amendement rendant
constructibles les terres de la ferme de
poult possible terrain pour pour le
futur camp des loges
bah ce terrain serait serait aussi dans
les tablettes des dirigeants du psg jean
claude blanc le directeur général va
donner sa décision d'ici à la fin de
l'année en attendant le psg a connu sa
première défaite ce week-end face à
saint-etienne au parc des princes
c'était pas la peine de le souligner
voilà mais ça c'est parce qu'ils vous
ont décidé d'aller à poissy place et ça
leur a pas porté chance venait à saint
quentin en yvelines dans ces cas là
merci anthony à lundi prochain l'actus
port aussi retrouver sur notre site
internet ainsi que l'ensemble de nos
émissions et de nos reportages le 7 8
qui est presque terminée pour ce 5
novembre juste un mot sur l'une des
informations du jour que nous avons
traité donc dans cette édition après
cécile duflot le week-end dernier c'est
au tour de jean marc ayrault d'évoquer
une possible réquisitions de logements
pour héberger les sans logis pas de
mesures annoncées mais une piste
sérieuse le premier ministre a demandé
un inventaire des bâtiments vides
pouvant accueillir des personnes sont
sans domicile
en attendant le préfet des yvelines a
décidé d'ouvrir 2 196 places
d'hébergement dans le département les
grands froids ne sont pas encore
installés mais le premier ministre
jean-marc ayrault le 1er novembre au
lendemain de la trêve hivernale s'est
voulu clair
la politique ne se base pas sur les
thermomètres en conséquence il faut des
centres d'accueil ouverts toute l'année
plus de places d'hébergement et pas
seulement quand les températures sont
négatives
du coup la préfecture des yvelines a
activé dès ce week-end le dispositif
hivernal d'urgence de 196 places
supplémentaires ouvertes soit une
augmentation de 39% par rapport à la
dernière campagne d'urgence une
mobilisation hivernale qui vient
compléter le dispositif permanent
d'accueil et d'hébergement qui compte
plus de 1100 18 places pérennes
ouverte donc toute l'année outre ce
dispositif le 115 le numéro d'urgence se
voit doté de quatre personnes en plus
le samu va augmenter ses maraudes et des
travailleurs sociaux supplémentaires
seront recrutés
car la problématique est globale et
implacable pas d'emploi pas de logement
on se retrouve demain mardi 18 heures
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8 en
direct sur tv fil 78 au programme
politique notamment avec une militante
très engagé de l'ump aurore bergé elle
fait campagne pour françois fillon après
avoir soutenu à valérie pécresse dans
les yvelines durant les législatives
elle fait campagne actuellement et elle
pourrait se présenter aux municipales
aussi à manille les amours 2014
son nom est également cité pour la
présidence des jeunes populaires des
jeunes ump
on en parlera avec elle sur ce plateau
demain rendez-vous en direct dès 18h
excellente soirée sur tf1